Boa noite a todos desculpem o atraso
fiquei realmente num trânsito de mais de
2 horas dentro do carro foi bem
complicado vamos discutir alguns artigos
aqui partir pras perguntas tá à medida
que vocês forem entrando por favor deem
boa noite para poder também cumprimentar
vocês primeo estudo é um estudo que
avalia se é saudável não comer à noite é
um estudo de corte prospectivo que a
valia se comer durante a noite está
associado ou não a risco aumentado de
mortalidade por todas as causas
especialmente entre os participantes que
consumiram mais calorias à noite então o
que que foi estudado se a alimentação
Noturna está associada ao risco de
mortalidade por todas as causas ao risco
de mortalidade por câncer ou ao risco de
mortalidade com diabetes também foram
analisadas eh situações para determinar
o momento a frequência ou a qualidade
dos alimentos nessa alimentação noturna
estavam Associados à mortalidade então
foram estudados 41.000 pessoas com idade
média de 46 anos metade homens metade
mulheres nos Estados Unidos um estudo de
coort prospectivo com segmento médio de
9 anos um estudo com muita muita gente
né 41.000 pessoas e um tempo longo de 9
anos né então estudo que tem peso a
ingestão alimentar foi avaliada no
início do estudo por meio de um
recordatório alimentar de 24 horas comer
à noite foi definido como comer entre as
22 e 4 horas da
manhã então os participantes foram
categorizados em um de seis
grupos dependendo de quando comeram
durante a noite boa noite Elane para
frequência os participantes foram
categor
como tendo comido uma duas ou mais vezes
durante a janela de alimentação noturna
e a qualidade dos alimentos foi baseada
no número total de quilocalorias
consumidas durante a noite e nos
alimentos específicos
consumidos os participantes com pior
qualidade alimentar tiveram as maiores
ingestões de energia total na faixa 723
kcor em média também tinha maior
quantidade dos açúcares adicionados
álcool e alimentos ricos em proteínas
grãos refinados e gorduras sólidas
enquanto aqueles com melhor qualidade
alimentar consumiram menos kilocalorias
no total e dessas Fontes que eu comentei
então Quais foram os resultados em
comparação com os participantes que não
comiam À noite as seguintes associações
foram relatadas para os que comiam à
noite então aumento de risco de
mortalidade por todas as causas para
quem comia à noite
2% maior nos participantes que comeram
entre 23 e horas meite 38% maior nos
participantes que comeram entre meite e
1 hora da manhã 10% maior nos
participantes que comeram uma vez
durante a noite 38% maior nos
participantes que comeram pelo menos
duas vezes durante a noite 21% maior nos
participantes que comeram alimentos pior
qualidade boa noite Adri bo TAM miquinha
e
Carlos em relação ao risco de
mortalidade por câncer foi
10% maior nos participantes que comeram
entre 1 e 2as da manhã 30% maior nos
participantes que comeram alimentos de
pior
qualidade e em relação ao risco de
mortalidade por diabetes foi 68 por
maior nos participantes que comeram
entre 22 e 23 horas 131 por maior noos
participantes que comeram entre 23 e
meia-noite
72 dos participantes comeram uma vez
durante a noite mas não duas vezes e
97% maior nos participantes que comeram
alimentos pior qualidade então o risco
de mortalidade geralmente Não
aumentou nos comedores noturnos que
comiam alimentos de melhor qualidade
então uma grande limitação desse estudo
que apesar de ter sido grande um tempo
bem considerável 9 anos é que um único
recordatório alimentar de 24 horas foi
coletado no início do estudo então o
relato de alimentação noturna nas
últimas 24 horas não é necessariamente
indicativo de ser um comedor noturno
regular então a inconsistência nas
associações entre os horários da
alimentação noturna e o desfecho de
mortalidade pode ser devido ao excesso
de grupos resultando em amostras
pequenas e poder limitado para detectar
a associações estatisticamente
significativas então tomem muito cuidado
faam um intervalo de pelo menos 3 horas
entre a última refeição e a hora de
dormir não comam depois das 22 horas
idealmente vão comer
eh até umas 7 horas da noite 8 horas da
noite quanto mais cedo vocês terminarem
de comer melhor mas especialmente não
como depois das 22
horas o próximo estudo que nós vamos
discutir aqui é um ensaio Clínico
randomizado em participantes com
covid-19 que nesse pacientes foi dado o
escaleno né o famoso escaleno que D lá
Ribeiro usa ou usava para aumentar o seu
colesterol escalena é um dos
intermediários na cascata do mevalonato
é uma cascata grande que tem bioquímica
que entre outras coisas é a Cascata que
é bloqueada quando você usa estatina e
também ela produz eh derivados da
vitamina K2 ela produz os calena ela
produz os docis produz com enzima q10 é
uma viem bioquímica importante no nosso
organismo Então nesse ensaio foi
utilizado o escaleno junto com o
medicamento habitual para
covid-19
e esse uso do escaleno foi demonstrado
que reduziu o risco de morte e
reinternação em comparação com o
tratamento habitual isolado Então o que
foi estudado foi a suplementação com
escaleno se reduzi ou não o risco de
mortalidade por todas as causas e
reinternação em participantes com
covid-19 foram 602 participantes
estudados com a idade média de 59 anos
sendo a maioria deles homens
64% 36% de mulheres e foi estudado entre
aqueles que foram internados com covid
em um hospital no Irã então foi um
estudo feito ali na Ásia Então como é
que foi estudado isso um est um estado
Clínico Desculpa um ensaio clínico
randomizado e os participantes receberam
um tratamento padrão que era eh não tá
bem especificado aqui mas imagina que
seja o tratamento sintomático mais cinco
gotas de
scaleno colocado sobre a língua a cada 4
horas ou o grupo controle não recebeu
nada além do tratamento padrão durante
os 5 dias os participantes estão foram
acompanhados por 30 dias após a alta
hospitalar o escaleno foi extraído do
Óleo de semente de abóbora e os
resultados que em comparação com o grupo
de controle ocorreram menos mortes no
grupo que utilizou calendo 56 versus 16
então uma diferença bem signicativa né
56 para
16 houve também menos reinternações por
covid-19 no grupo que usou escaleno 141
reinternações verso 58 casos
respectivamente então grupo esalen R
internou menos então a dosagem do
scaleno não foi especificada embora as
gotas contivessem 10 mg de scaleno por
então aqui é uma uma alera para vocês
que além da vitamina D além da vitamina
C além da EV mectina além aí do da da
curcumina e vários outros agentes aí
nainas nac vocês têm a opção também do
escaleno para tratamento do covid tá
então isso aqui é uma coisa interessante
que eu não conhecia também o scalen é um
suplemento pouco conhecido né pouco
utilizado no Brasil então o último
trabalho que nós vamos discutir hoje
antes das respostas das
perguntas antes deixa eu também
cumprimentar Marli Boa noite Marli é uma
metanálise de ensaios clínicos
sodomizado sobre o uso da rumão
pomegranate para redução da pressão
arterial tanto a sistólica quanto a
diastólica então o que que foi estudado
uso a suplementação da Roman para
controle da pressão arterial sistólica
diastólica um total de 928 homens e
mulheres foram estudadas com idades
entre 21 a 70 anos a pressão arterial S
hisória média de 108 até 167 e a di
estória de 67 até 98 Então os
participantes eh foram incluídos pessoas
sem problemas de saúde conhecidos e
pessoas com cidro metabólica pessoas com
diabetes tipo 2 doença renal crônica
síndrome dos ovários policísticos
doença hepática gordurosa não alcoólica
sobrepeso obesidade e doenças cardíacas
ou dislipidemia então foi uma meta
análise ou seja juntaram vários estudos
22 ensaios clínicos andom zados foram
juntados nesse estudo 10 ensaios foram
realizados no Irã três ensaios foram
realizados no Reino Unido dois
ensaios foram realizados cada nos
Estados Unidos Israel e Sérvia e o
ensaio foi realizado na Tunísia na
Grécia e na Bósnia e tem dificuldade de
falar esse nome na Bósnia e Herzegovina
então 15 ensaios
eh foram administrados suco de romã em
doses diárias de 45 a 550 ml e sete
ensaios administraram extrato de romã em
doses diárias entre 225 e 1500
MG Então os comparadores incluíram
Placebo água em nenhuma intervenção a
duração da intervenção foi de uma a 48
semanas então muito variado entre os
estudos que colocados aqui nessa
metanálise bem grande né de 1 até 48
semanas aí a diferença Então quais foram
os resultados a suplementação com Roman
reduziu a pressão arterial sistólica em
8 mm de mercúrio e a diastólica em 3 mm
de mercúrio sendo a certeza da evidência
classificada como moderada para ambos os
desfechos então nas análises subgrupos a
redução da pressão arterial sistólica
foi maior nos ensaios que recrutaram os
participantes com hipertensão que tinha
uma pressão arterial sistólica acima de
130 e nos ensaios que administraram o
suco de Roman em dose diária de 200 ml
ou menos estranho né 200 ml ou menos era
para ser mais né mas enfim Então para
que que serve esse estudo para vocês
terem essa informação de que o suco de
Roman é uma boa alternativa para
controle de pressão arterial bem vamos
agora responder às dúvidas de vocês deix
Abrir o documento
aqui são 14 perguntas que temos
hoje vou dividir a tela
primeira pergunta da
Darling a gente sabe que as picadas do
PNI por ser multidoses incluem compos
como timerosal além do fosfato de
alumínio aqui no Brasil O Senhor conhece
as clínicas que ofertem calendários
alternativos para pentes obtenção de
monodoses não não conheço para diminuir
os efeitos colaterais deletérios e
acumulativos não conheço infelizmente
não viu eu não não sou uma pessoa muito
interada nas práticas que existem em
clínicas de vacina Tá então não é um
assunto que eu domine particularmente eu
não conheço esse mundo das Clínicas de
vacina tão bem para te responder isso
aqui ah
infelizmente nesse ponto estou não estou
sabendo o Carlos pergunta D Alan gostari
de insistir no assunto omega-3 presente
em cereais para melhor poder planejar a
dieta bem como para evitar o excesso
ômega-3 que também é prejudicial vejo
como muito importante saber quanto o
corpo humano absorve desse nutriente
provindo de de cerea isso é variante é
variante de pessoa para pessoa tá isso
aí você não vai descobrir facilmente não
considerando que é muito fácil fazer
esse estudo não não é muito fácil fazer
não em ambiente acadêmico médico até
mesmo no Brasil porque ninguém o faz
porque as absorções são variáveis de
pessoa para pessoa e as enzimas que
convertem uma forma de ômega-3 na outra
são também variáveis de pessoa para
pessoa isso não é simples de fazer não
tá na minha inia ignorância entendo que
bastaria selecionar um grupo razoável de
pessoas classificadas com diversas f
etárias e também por de massa corporal
diabéticos não diabéticos ou outra que
possa incluir na absorção e verificar a
evolução da relação omega3 e omega6
mediante a gestão de áre de cereais
moídos no momento do consumo como
linhaça eu não tenho esses dados para te
apresentar tá e como eu te falei a a
absorção não é simples de determinar não
existindo estudos até mesmo para
comparar manteiga com queijo no consumo
essa sugestão acima não seria de grande
interesse
sim mas eu não trabalho em institutos de
pesquisa então você pode deixar essa
pesquisa talvez no Instagram na conta de
Instagram de
alguma Instituto que faça essas
pesquisas mas não é simples de fazer
não Marilda quais são os sintomas da
prostatite sem neoplasia e tipo de
tratamento então prostatite aguda é uma
coisa prostatite crônica e outra tá
prostatite aguda os sintomas é febre dor
importante na região
abdominal inferior dor importante no
escroto ou no perí a dor pode até
irradiar pras coxas então é dor febre
queda de estado geral prostração pode
também ter falta de fome que
forexia e se a infecção alastrar ela
pessa pode ter uma cemia prostatite
crônica os sintomas são bem parecidos
com hpb é jato urinário fraco é rência
por urinar é dificuldade base bexiga é
dor perineal dor abdominal Baixa também
mas menos intensa e a dor também é mais
longa mais prolongada e não é
acompanhado por
febre tá Esses são os sintomas da
prostatite Marilda também eh quais são
os exames para detectar uma possível
prostatite exame de urina por cultura
cultura do jato médio também você pode
estar solicitando hemog completo
ultrassom de próstata de
bexiga exames Gerais aí para ver se tá
com infecção VHS proteína ser reativa tá
hemograma esse tipo de
coisa Marta D Alan o que acha de usar o
óleo essencial de Líbano em sinergia com
óleo essencial de cúrcuma
acho uma boa tem efeito potencializado
tem tem estudo mostrando que a bzu junto
com a curcumina tem um efeito eh
cinético sim penso nessa opção para
ajudar nas dores da artrose pode usar
sim você pode usar essa associação do
olle Essencial de olíbano com a cúrcuma
sem nenhum
problema Marilda o que que pode concluir
quando existe uma grande oscilação nos
valores de PSA Isso aqui é uma tentativa
de analisar o exame de um paciente né
que não é correto vocês sabem disso tá
se o PSA está oscilando muito tem que
avaliar primeiramente se não tá tendo
uma prostatite segundo se não pode ser
eh realmente um problema mais sério
então tem que fazer geralmente uma
ressonância nuclear de próstata
multiparamétrica e se tiver eh alguma
imagem sugestiva de pirads 4 pirad 5 se
indica biópsia Tá mas geralmente quando
o PSA sobe muito rápido é prostati
e o tratamento é com
antibiótico esses números
especificamente eu não vou avaliar
porque isso não é o objetivo do
do do grupo aqui do
YouTube A vitamina C é mais eficiente
tomando 1 g ou duas vezes de 500 quanto
mais você conseguir e picar vitamina C
tomar mais vezes ao longo do dia é
melhor então se você melhor tomar duas
vezes de 500 do que uma de 1 g é melhor
tomar C de 200 do que do de 500 Tá
quanto mais você conseguir tomar picada
é melhor só que aí chega um momento fica
pouco prático isso
daí os protocolos após vacina
disponibilizados pelo Senor pode ser
administrado para crianças com ajuste de
dose sim tem que fazer o ajuste de dose
ser orientado por um Pediatra
Tiago no frasco do Óleo de orégano diz
para não usar por mais de duas semanas
com relação ao chá de orégano tem
problema de fazer uso contínuo não não
tem tem problema de fazer uso contínuo E
essas recomendações geralmente são para
resguardar o fabricante tá não é que
isso daí seja uma verdade
absoluta pode tomar com enzima que10
azul de metileno você tá querendo saber
se pode associar os dois sim pode
associar os dois se essa que é a sua
pergunta
Alex pode experimentar com enzima que10
e B12 junto
pode minha esposa está com um mioma no
útero que teve um aumento de tamanho
dentro de 4 meses sendo a ginecologista
segunda ginecologista ele está crescendo
para fora do útero mas não passou nenhum
tratamento que eu posso fazer para
tratar você pode usar iodo ou na forma
de lugol ou na forma de iodo
kelp tá é um tratamento que vai fazer
efeito Se utilizar durante vários meses
não é uma coisa que vai resolver em
pouco tempo falei com ela e parei
tomando o CDs não sei dizer CDs vai
funcionar nesse caso aqui Não conheço
nenhum caso de mioma que curou com o CDs
dmso Poderia ajudar sim como tem efeito
antiinflamatório Poderia ajudar mas
também não tem um efeito muito
específico para mioma não que eu saiba
eh qual é a diferença entre lipoproteína
a e apolipoproteína a São eh tipos
diferença é porque na verdade a
apolipoproteína a ela tá presente em
várias frações de colesterol ela tá
presente no HDL e colesterol
e também no idl
apoproteína B ela tá presente no velho
idl no
LDL Então na verdade a lipoproteína a é
um complexo de proteína com gordura e a
lipoproteína a é uma fração prote que
tentar em vários eh complexos de lip
proteína tá essa que é a diferença sãoa
coas diferentes
tá na verdade deix eu até te dar uma
resposta um pouquinho mais completa
é meio confuso também né esses termos
aí então ah só para detalhar um
pouquinho mais a a resposta
tá apolipoproteína a apo A1 tá que é o
segundo termo aí da pergunta é o
principal componente proteico da
partícula de HDL né como eu falei ele
proteína de alta densidade ele participa
do transporte colesterol sendo
responsável por remover o excesso de
colesterol dos tecidos e levá-lo de
volta ao fígado níveis mais alos de apo
A1 são considerados protetores já a
lipoproteína a ou lipoe né que o pessoal
americano chama de lipo é uma partícula
semelhante ao LDL é uma lipoproteína de
baixa densidade sendo formada pela
junção da apolipoproteína BC que é um
tipo de apob tá como eu falei que tá
presente no LDL
com a apolipoproteína
A então uma junção de apolipoproteína B
100 com
AP apolipoproteína a minúsculo não a
maiúsculo a minúsculo então níveis
elevados de
LPA estão associadas a maior risco
cardiovascular bom e ela pode causar
ateroesclerose mecanismos similares ao
LDL tá então em resumo apo A1 é um
componente proteico principal da HDL tem
função protetora e o LPA é uma partícula
semelhante ao LDL que tem ap B 100 na
sua composição junto com o Apple l a ou
seja o Apple com a minúsculo é confuso
mesmo tá pessoal é confuso isso daí
tá eu espero que tenha ficado um
pouquinho mais claro para você el como é
que é
isso Tiago adicionar outras fibras no
suco de frutas como chia linhaça diminui
o pico iico sim diminui o açúcar precisa
estar dentro das células e fibras da
fruta para não causar não se você
ingerir fibra junto com suco sim vai
diminuir o pico glicêmico is
acontece Doutor por existe esse risco de
comer à noite eu não entendi qual a
relação do horário tá isso já é
conhecido há alguns anos tá aqueles
estudos feitos com ramadã mostrar
aumento de risco Porque durante o ramadã
os muçulmanos só podem comer durante a
noite não podem comer durante o dia tá o
entendimento é principal é que essa
caloria toda que você ingere À noite ela
vai ser totalmente armazenada e ela não
vai ser queimada como fonte de energia e
esse excesso de caloria que tá sendo
armazenado acaba inflamando o organismo
tá Então essa é a principal razão porque
comer muito tarde da noite não faz bem
pra saúde tá
boa noite marl boa noite
Marta TAM miquinha a vitamina C pode ser
de forma normal após 50 anos ou só
lipossomal não lipossomal tem absorção
maior né Se puder usar lipossomal melhor
eu não conheço nenhuma marca lipossomal
no Brasil não tá miquinha
tá pode tomar n prolina para a
inflamação no
organismo
NS prolina eu não lembro de ter lido
sobre isso não tá vou até dar uma
checada nisso agora aqui
sim isso eu não conhecia mas tem
evidência assim que o o peptídio ntil
prolina e compostos relacionados com
ntil seril aspartil lisil prolina tem
propriedades antiinflamatórias Eu nunca
usei isso tá sinceramente e podem ter
potencial tratamento de condições
inflamatórias parece que atuam em vias
de sinalização e ativação de mediadores
inflamatórios tem um modelo experimental
de cit camundongos que foi utilizado e
teve uma resposta boa inibindo a
expressão de fatores pró-inflamatórios
aparentemente só foi estudado em estudos
pré-clínicos não foram feitos em humanos
pelo que eu tô entendendo
aqui você viu isso Onde
taquinha se puder me responder Acho
interessante isso
aqui dout anit é bom para
amibiase Sim pode ser utilizado para
amibiase sim tá mas ah porque é tão
difícil Se Curar disso você pode usar a
Anita durante três dias consecutivos tá
para a mebas
Ok pelo fato de ser de amplo espectro
pega o minto né que é parasita grande
extracelular e pega prot usuário
também então você usa duas vezes ao dia
durante uns quro dias para isso daí a
dose crianças acima de 1 ano é 0,3 ml
por kg da suspensão oral
Qual o horário correto que o organismo
faz limpeza em
nós então você tem que manter o jejum
desse durante esse horário para fazer
Inclusive a a a realmente a a limpeza do
organismo Tá quanto mais cedo você parar
de comer melhor eu não recomendo comer
depois das 10 horas da noite por causa
estudo que eu mostrei para
vocês uma farmaceutica passou para você
a NS prolina tá mas você comprou isso
Onde na
[Música]
manipulação Tá legal obrigado pela Mação
viu
taquinha agora Lembrando que a
nitazoxanida que a Anita Não é a
primeira opção para mibas tá a primeira
opção é Metronidazol ou tinidazol certo
mais perguntas
pessoal excesso de ômega3 pode elevar o
colesterol causa placa de
ateroma nunca vi nada a respeito el
mas é muito difícil ter excesso de
ômega-3 tá tem que tá tomando umas oito
cápsulas por dia durante um período
longo para acontecer
isso já usei Doutor mas não me curei por
isso perguntei da Anita Então pode usar
Anita né não é a primeira opção mas se
você já usou
Metronidazol tinidazol não
resolveu sim Tô comendo aqui umas
mandiocas aqui acabei de chegar em em
casa bateu um pouquinho de
fome
eh estat tar quer dier o quê pra gente
encerrar a Live é isso podemos encerrar
a Live Sim que que vocês você tem mais
perguntas
Ah entendi você tá falando do horário
não mas não são 10 horas da noite ainda
não viu ô TAM
miquinha são 9 horas da noite ainda né
não são 10 horas da noite não mas você
tem razão quanto mais cedo melhor tá é
porque hoje Realmente fiquei preso no
trânsito
agora que eu entendi o que você quis
dizer aqui você
tava apontando a ironia né eu tá falando
de não comer à noite tô comendo aqui na
frente de vocês né Tá certo É tem
razão não não quer dizer que seja ruim
não tá É porque geralmente vocês têm os
protocolos É só por isso mas se não
funcionou tinidazol petron AOL usa Anita
tá
bom tem mais perguntas pessoal
[Música]
de nada Adriano
existe uma dose segura para tomar outras
doses de vitamina D você pode tomar até
umas 50.000 unidades por dia em caso de
emergência de uma
infecção por uns uma semana mais ou
menos mais aí depois de desse período
você interrompe essa dose alta
Tá
ok 50.000 unidades por dia a por até uma
semana mas a gente pode fazer por
exemplo injetável 500.000 unidades de
uma vez porque ela fica num tecido
gorduroso fica armazenada num liberada
todo uma vez vai liberando aos poucos Tá
mas via
oral por volta de 50.000 unidades por
dia por se bem que o Dr se Gal Coimbra
já falou de tomar uma dose única via
oral
de 100 ou 200.000 unidades eu já vi ele
comentando sobre isso
Ah mas aí seria um dia só
tá de nada TAM miquinha ficou feliz aí
que você Aprecia os meus
esforços não quis cancelar
né a Live né Por causa infelizmente
Quando eu vou pro ABC que atualmente é
são poucos dias do
mês eu pegar muito trânsito voltando
aqui paraa minha casa então hoje
particularmente trânsito tava muito
ruim é a situação que tá acontecendo no
Rio Grande do Sul é muito chocante
[Música]
mesmo é uma tristeza muito grande mé
contto com você Adriana vamos ajudar
eles com doações eu fiz as minhas
doações mas tô pensando até fazer uma
aula para arrecadar doações para
eles quanto menor o pth deve se diminuir
a vitamina D sim
é mas não é a única coisa que baixa o
pth uso da vitamina D não tem outros
fatores
tá que pode interferir na vitamina D
D mas sim se tiver com pth na faixa de
20 é porque provavelmente você tá
convertendo bastante vitamina D3 em 1,25
hidroxi vitamina D
sim eu doe através de instituição viu
não recomendo que vocês façam a doação
através de governo não eu não
confio mas tem um programa do Correios
também que estão
eh fazendo o transporte de doações né de
de itens né lá para lá aí aí não é
doação de dinheiro doação de roupa e
outros itens para as pessoas
desabrigadas
Hã Eu não tô lembrando o nome da
instituição porque quem fez foi minha
esposa tá eu fiz pedi para ela fazer meu
nome depois eu vejo com ela direitinho
eu falo para vocês
Ok mais perguntas
pessoal bem pessoal vou encerrar aqui tá
bom obrigado pela presença de vocês
desculpem novamente o atraso até semana
que
vem então um grande abraço nós nos vemos
em breve tchau tchau